because they're scared that's why
they're trying to find ways either to
get out of Elections or get me out of
the way
[Music]
the police have given us publish they
had to proved the root of the rally and
suddenly this morning the permission was
taken away all the 12 parties sitting in
government and their backers their
petrified of Elections because so far in
the last eight months
out of the 37 by-elections my party has
won 30 out of them they want either to
imprison me or to disqualify me because
they are scared that this my party is
one of the most popular party in
Pakistan's history
[Music]
foreign
attempt on me I had three bullets in my
leg so I couldn't go out of my house how
do you
deal with 77 cases I mean how many court
appearances do you make so it is just
one other way of getting me out of the
way to contest the elections
thanks everyone
my life is under threat because the
people who who try to assassinate behind
power and so we've asked from the gods
we want protection the court must give
us me protection
before I can appear in courts the people
who I have nominated in my assassination
attempt are sitting in power
foreign